Let's go to our caller from the four 103 area
code, the old stomping ground of the David
Pakman show.
Who's calling today from four one three.
Hello? Yes.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Hi, this is Mike kin from Western mass.
Hey Mike, what's up?
So, um, I just have some questions about,
um, your position on health care.
Okay.
So, um, a lot of the progressive media has
been saying that, you know, TYT or secular
talk or other media have been saying that
Bernie's Medicare for all Virgin Vernon's
version is the populous position.
But if you look at the polls, um, it's actually,
um, the Medicare for all who wanted, or the
public option, which is the popular position.
Sorry, did you get cut off or was, was there
a question there?
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, I got cut off.
So my question is, what's your position on,
what's your position on Medicare for all specific,
specifically Bernie's position because, um,
according to the polls, the apocalypse position
is Medicare for all who want it?
The public option.
I don't know what, what do you, according
to the polls, what, what does that mean?
According to the polls, the popular, popular
or popular list?
I'm having a really hard time understanding
what you're saying.
Okay.
Pop folk.
Well, I guess popular position is um, public
corruption.
Okay.
I've not seen those polls and the polls have
nothing to do with what I think would be best.
So here's the deal.
The public option is a milk toast half measure.
The best studies I've seen say that if you
pass a public option, it will reduce premiums
by about 7%.
And of course premiums often go up by 10%
every year.
So it would basically save part of one year's
increase in premiums.
It's a very milk toast half measure.
It doesn't really fix the problems we have
Medicare for all fixes.
Lots of the problems that we have.
There are some issues.
No plan is perfect.
There are some issues with Medicare for all,
uh, one of them being that, uh, the, the best
studies I've seen say in order to really deliver
the care quality level at the accessibility
level that Bernie wants, that it's simply
going to cost way more than he says.
That might still be okay.
Right?
Like we might say, it'll cost way more, but
that's okay.
Um, but yeah, I mean, as the polls you're
citing, I haven't seen them.
I, I don't know anything about that.
Okay.
So let's say that hypothetically because you
didn't see it, let's say that it is a public
option is the most popular position among
the general population, but you still want
to push for Bernie's version of Medicare for
all.
Uh, so my view on this is not informed by
what people like, I mean, listen, 60 something
million people voted for Donald Trump.
It happened to be fewer than the number that
voted for Hillary.
But like I, I don't really care about it being
popular or unpopular.
My view is what do the studies say about how
to deliver the best care most effectively
to the most number of people.
And the public option is just, it's just a
half measure and it won't do very much.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Thanks for the answer.
I appreciate that.
All right, Mike, great to hear from you.
Great to hear from folks in, uh, in, in Western
Massachusetts.